je suis du gouvernement collégial pour
nouvelle calédonie après la démission
aujourd'hui des indépendantistes kanaks
qui dispose de cinq membres de
l'exécutif sur 11 le front de libération
nationale kanak et socialiste a justifié
ce départ en raison du processus de
vente d'une usine de nickel d'un groupe
brésilien
un projet qui avait entraîné des
contestations sur le territoire en
novembre dernier un nouveau gouvernement
devra être élue dans un délai de 15
jours selon le statut de l'accord de
nouméa et pour soutenir la caisse
présidente de l'assemblée de la province
sud de la nouvelle-calédonie les
indépendantistes veulent se servir du
gouvernement pour gagner des points au
prochain vote
cette double défaite qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui les indépendantistes
souhaite gagner le troisième référendum
puisque vous le savez il y en a trois il
ya trois référendum qui sont prévus dans
l'accord de nouméa en cas de vote non à
l'indépendance
donc ce troisième référendum il doit
avoir lieu dans les prochains mois et
les indépendantistes bas souhaitent
reprendre la main sur le gouvernement
pour essayer de se servir du
gouvernement pour gagner des points
mais le sentiment qu'on a c'est que le
choix qui a été fait par exemple par les
indépendantistes d'aller vers la
violence vers la quasi-guerre civile
puisqu'ils ont organisé un conflit armé
des exactions déblocage de 2 route de
blocage de la liberté de travailler des
calédoniens fait que les gens qui
étaient indécis ou ou indépendantistes
modéré il ya quatre mois
s'interroge sur le projet de société que
veulent les indépendantistes si au
moindre désaccord ils vont ils vont à la
guerre civile
le système de la nouvelle calédonie
c'est que les voix des indépendantistes
pèse plus lourd dans les institutions
que les voix des noms d'indépendantistes
et donc ils se sont servis de ce système
là qui est en fait un système qui est
qui est un peu anti démocratique mais
qui avait été mis en place il ya trente
ans pour ramener la paix en nouvelle
calédonie ils se servent aujourd'hui de
ce système là pour prendre une majorité
au gouvernement qu'ils n'ont pas dans
les urnes
donc c'est donc donc à ce titre on peut
considérer effectivement que c'est un
coup d'état parce que ça ne correspond
absolument pas ce que les calédoniens
ont décidé
ya quelques mois